Optimal at this altitude.
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
No else.
You posting a question?
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
This podcast is brought to you by four sigmatic.
I reached out to these Finnish folks,
young entrepreneurs for talented.
After a acrobat introduced me to one of their products,
which is mushroom coffee.
This specific one includes Chaga and lion's mane and it knocked my socks off.
I highly recommend if you try it,
you start with half a packet.
It's very strong and lights you up like a Christmas tree in the best way
possible.
People are always asking me what I use for cognitive enhancement and for right
now this is the answer.
I try to force this on all of my house guests.
It is a hell of a thing.
If I have employees or people come over who are working on projects with me,
I always try to feed it to them because I'm going to get the limitless effect
and get a lot more out of them.
The first time I mentioned this product and four sigmatic on the podcast,
their products sold out in less than a week,
so you may want to check them out soon.
If you're listening to this and the coffee tastes like coffee,
it takes just seconds to prepare with hot water.
And oddly enough,
only includes 40 milligrams of caffeine.
So it has less than half of what you would get in a regular cup of coffee.
I don't get any jitters,
acid reflux or any stomach burn,
any of that.
It's very unusual and very,
very cool.
So if you don't like caffeine,
they also offer very strong,
but caffeine free mushroom elixirs,
which I will sometimes have in the evening.
I find Chaga specifically to be very,
very grounding and earthy.
So that is another option.
And I have a cupboard full of their products,
uh,
at the moment,
which is right around the corner of my kitchen.
You can try something,
you can try a sample pack,
which is great.
Also right now by going to foursigmatic.com forward slash Tim,
that's foursigmatic,
I g,
m,
a t,
I c.
Dot com forward slash Tim and use the Code Tim Tim to get 20% off of your first
order and they're not that expensive anyway.
If you are in the experimental mindset,
I do not think you'll be disappointed,
so try them.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for many,
many years.
I absolutely love audio books in there.
One of my favorite ways to pass the time when I travel,
I'm on the road all the time and audible allows me to consume many more books
than I possibly could otherwise.
I've two audio books to recommend right off the bat.
The first is perhaps my favorite audio book of all time and it's the only
audiobook I've wanted to listen to twice in a row.
The graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
It's amazing and you will thank me.
There are a few different versions.
I like the version that Neil narrates himself,
one of the most soothing voices of all time.
The second book is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
p,
O,
t,
s,
which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what would
later become the four hour workweek.
So go to audible.com forward slash Tim and you can choose one of these two books
or any of many,
many other options that could be books,
magazines,
and much more.
As a listener of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can also access a free 30 day trial.
Just go to audible.com forward slash Tim you can't make more time,
but you can make the most of it,
so turn your travel or your commute into something more with a free trial at
audible.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim to start now and get your free 30 day trial.
Hey,
hello ladies and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss show.
My dog Molly is staring me directly in the face from three feet away,
but that is not relevant to this particular introduction.
The Tim Ferriss show.
What is it?
Well.
My job is every episode to deconstruct world class performers,
people who are the best at what they do to give you tactics,
routines,
habits,
Cetera that you can apply immediately in test in your own lives.
This particular episode has been requested in requested and requested.
People ask me,
Tim,
why aren't you talking about relationships when you're going to talk about
relationships?
Why are you so private?
Why are you dodging the questions will no longer.
Folks,
I am going to speak with Esther Perel.
I've wanted to speak with this particular psychotherapist for many years and for
good reason.
She has been called the most important game changer in sexuality and relational
health since Doctor Ruth by the New York Times who featured her in a cover
story,
her ted talks,
one of which she actually basically winged off the cuff,
which is amazing to me.
Her talks on maintaining desire and rethinking infidelity of more than 17
million views and she's tested and been exposed to everything imaginable in 34
years of running her private therapy practice in New York City.
In this episode,
we explore everything imaginable.
We talk about her life story,
how to find and convinced mentors who can change your life.
For instance,
what she's learned from Holocaust survivors,
but then we get into what she is very much known for.
We discuss topics like polyamory and in all of its close cousins.
Is there such a thing as too much honesty in relationships we answered or
attempt to answer questions like,
can we want what we already have?
Why do happy people cheat and much,
much more.
She has many,
many case studies because she's been practicing this in the real world and messy
reality for so long.
A little bit of background on Esther who have had a chance to spend time with in
personnel and is just more impressive.
The more time I spend with her.
She's the author of the international bestseller mating in captivity.
Many of you have heard of this.
It's been translated into 26 languages.
She is fluent in nine of them.
I've heard her in person do this in a crowded room going from person to person
in different languages.
It blows my mind,
has a language nut.
This Belgian native now brings her multicultural pulse to a new book,
the state of affairs and subtitle,
rethinking infidelity,
which is out October,
2017 through Harper Collins.
Right now though,
what you can check out of hers and you should check out is a brand new audible
original audio series.
Where should we begin?
And she's cocreating this and hosting it,
uh,
with audible.
And this looks at specific couples and walks you through their issues and how
she would recommend they address them.
So check that out.
Where should we begin?
You can say hello to her on the socials at Facebook for instance,
dot com,
forward slash S.
Dot.
Parell p.
E.
R.
L.
But I had a blast with this.
It's going to ax expose my,
my sensitive,
vulnerable underbelly for those people who have been asking for all this
relationship stuff.
So feel free to ridicule me on the Internet.
Usually don't even have to ask.
That just comes with this job that I've created for myself.
So without further ado,
please enjoy this wide ranging conversation with as their parole,
as they're welcome to the show.
I am thrilled to finally have connected with you and you have one of the hottest
possible areas of expertise imaginable.
And there's so many questions that I would like to ask and so many questions
that my fans would like to ask.
But I thought we could start with a bit of background and if you could tell us
just a bit about where you grew up and what your childhood was like.
I think that'd be good as context to get us started.
So,
um,
I grew up in Antwerp in Belgium mostly,
and two of his,
the Flemish part of Belgium.
Um,
and I was there til I finished high school.
I grew up with,
I have a big brother who is 12 years older than me,
so I was the,
the young girl and my parents who were actually Polish refugees who came to
Belgium after the war.
I'm from Belgium,
a move to Jerusalem.
And I studied at the Hebrew University in Jerusalem and I lived there for almost
six years.
And then I came to Cambridge,
Massachusetts to finish my master's degree.
And,
um,
and I really thought I was coming for one year to America.
Um,
but that one year became two years in Cambridge.
And then after that I came to New York and I thought I would do that for one
year because I wanted to have the New York experience and I never used my return
ticket.
Here I am.
You're still having the New York.
I'm still heading the York fans.
Exactly to you as I understand it grew up among Holocaust survivors and,
and I would love to hear you elaborate on that experience and what it was like,
what you,
what you learned from it.
And uh,
and then we can talk about,
I'd like to talk about Jerusalem,
but I am am very interested as many people are in the history of the Holocaust.
But even more than that,
the,
the personal experience,
the lived experience and there's a book called if this is a man and there's
another book called the truce,
both the written by Primo Levy,
which was recommended to me by the illusionist David Blaine,
who actually has primo levies,
inmate number or prisoner number tattooed on his forum.
And it was one of the most impactful books I would say I've read in the last 10
years,
but I have no direct experience with Holocaust survivors.
What was that?
What was that like and what did you learn?
Hmm,
so interesting that we're starting from there.
So I think that if this was a man by Kramer,
Lavey is one of the most powerful books a one ought to read.
I think it's a,
it's a unique,
unique,
a testament.
So it's very simple.
There were 60,000 Jews in Belgium before the war.
Uh,
the vast majority of them were decimated,
uh,
throughout the war and in camps.
And so after the war in group of Eastern European Jews basically came to Belgium
for two.
All kinds of means.
That's kind of where they arrived.
And my parents who were both the sole survivors of their entire family,
which means 200 people lost,
I guess on every side.
They were both the youngest in their families.
My mother was in the camps from 18 to 22,
and my father from a 25 to 31 actually because the worst started very early for
them.
So they,
the,
they came with nothing to buy,
to be there for three months.
They were illegal refugees.
No,
they were illegal refugees for three months.
We're meant to continue from there to other countries where they had been given
refugee status,
but they didn't,
they chose not to leave.
And so they stayed for another five years as,
as illegal refugees in Belgium,
which is very telling for me right now with what's going on in our country here.
Um,
and I'm born later.
So when I am born in 58,
they already found a way to legalize themselves,
to become a Belgian citizens.
And,
um,
and I grew up in a different environment,
but I am growing up in a community of 20,000 Jews that are all Holocaust
survivors.
That's basically all we knew in the Jewish community.
Of course there was the larger Belgian community around.
Um,
and you know,
you saw numbers,
you asked,
why don't we have grandparents?
You asked whether these numbers you,
you,
um,
you know,
they,
it was kind of in the,
in,
he'd came with mother's milk is the best way I could say it.
It was so ever present.
We spoke Yiddish,
German,
Polish,
French and Flemish in my home.
Uh,
depending on the subject matter we changed and depending on who we're speaking
to whom the language change,
but they were,
they were five vibrant,
interchangeable languages going on the whole time.
And if you can imagine that the language is a door to a world,
then you can imagine how many words were coexisting at the same time.
That had nothing to do with each other.
Actually.
Um,
I grew up above the store in a,
because most of the Jews of Antwerp,
we're actually are in the diamond business.
Uh,
my family was among the 2% that were not.
And so they had clothing stores and I grew up in the neighborhood where they
were two Jewish families.
So it's like the Deli store with the foreigner in the neighborhood,
you know,
and you know who they are,
the two foreigners and they have an accent.
And they look different and the whole thing.
And I lived above the store and,
and in this very popular,
um,
neighborhoods,
lower middle class neighborhood.
Um,
and where we spoke actually not even just Flemish,
but we spoke dialect,
Flemish from the street,
like from the hood and the equivalent of the hood basically.
And I would straddle back and forth.
You know,
the,
one of the ways I can describe it is my father,
when he turned 50,
he had two birthday parties.
One birthday party was for his Jewish survivor friends that took place in
Yiddish and in Polish.
And with a lot of vodka,
one birthday party was with his Flemish friends.
And that was in dialect.
And with a lot of beer
and by the code,
by the drinks,
you knew exactly which words you were traveling in and how,
how you had to behave and,
uh,
how much you could show that side of you versus the other side of you.
Um,
and you know,
and there was a sense I think maybe more than anything,
when you grow up in that kind of a community,
you,
you grew up with the notion of impermanence that what is today could disappear
at any moment.
I think that's probably one of the strongest experiences.
You don't ever think that there is a notion of,
uh,
you know,
what is now will be there tomorrow.
You'd never know.
And so you learn to adapt to that notion of impermanence,
of insecurity if you want.
And,
um,
and my parents were,
were both evolved.
You know,
they loved life.
They didn't survive for nothing.
They were going to enjoy at best.
And,
uh,
um,
as I have often said,
they understood the erotic as an antidote.
Death as in they knew how to keep themselves alive and,
and then enjoy.
They were not,
everybody was like that.
You had very different kind of moods.
They were storytellers.
So people would come from everywhere and they would tell about their life and
their experiences and they were good story tellers,
which means that they knew how to screen out.
And two could make you laugh and they didn't make you completely tense when you
would listen.
And everybody wanted to know their stories.
They were amazing,
amazing,
amazing stories of,
of,
of survival,
uh,
of subversion of,
you know,
my dad was illiterate,
he spoke five languages,
but he was basically illiterate and he was a grand grand,
a human being,
you know,
who had done a lot and had saved quantities of people because yeah,
I would say maybe the best,
the strongest value,
uh,
in that,
in,
in that community or not the strongest.
We're one of the very strong values.
One was definitely decency,
you know,
how you behave towards your fellow other people.
And the other one was,
uh,
um,
how would you say that in English to manage sweet,
smart to be street smart,
you know,
to know,
to survive basically to find your way out of situations and to be able to,
to survive.
Survival was the central organizing experience of all these people.
And then the second experience was revival.
So many different directions that I would love to take this.
So I'll try to do it one at a time.
Dialect,
Flemish from the hood.
Could you give us any example of what street Flemish sounds like?
Correct.
Well,
I think that is efficacy man's vibes.
What so what did you just say?
Yes,
dude.
Do you want me to say this in Antwon,
in Antrop dialect?
How would you say?
How are you in like what's up?
Say that one more time.
Who called it?
Oh boy,
yes,
I'll,
I'll save my embarrassing rehearsal for when we meet in person.
Did that element
and that can cook Alamo Vincent's Fifth Element and they're going to get tokens
in dangles efficacy.
I think you might've just insulted my ancestors,
but I'm not sure what just happened.
I said I could say all of this in Antrop dialect,
but in order to be sure we all understand it,
I'm going to tell my stories in English.
That is a fantastic idea,
so thank you for that.
I love languages,
so I just wanted to hear something that I had never heard before.
You mentioned that your parents were sole survivors in their families.
If I heard you correctly,
when you look at your parents,
uh,
and I,
I don't know if it was simply because of their age,
uh,
or or other factors,
but when you look at your parents,
so that would be the primary focus,
but at end at other soul survivors,
what did they credit the survival too?
Oh,
that is a great question.
I did go to,
I did get to ask them this question.
So mmm.
My mother,
she first spent one year in the woods at 18 running from farm to farm hiding in
the woods of Poland.
And then she was so terrified that she actually surrendered by herself to a
camp,
to a labor camp,
to a man's camp because she thought if I am in a camp at least probably will put
me in the kitchens or in the laundry and I could at least wake up every morning
in the same place.
My mother ended up going to nine different labor camps now,
labor camps where generally next door to the concentration camps and as long as
you could work,
you were in labor camp.
If you were not selected that morning for transport then you could continue
work.
But the distinction is often a very narrow distinction.
And my father was in 14 camps,
um,
and my mother definitely so the rest of their families was either a guest in
Treblinka or in um,
honestly it's basically his family in Auschwitz,
her family and Treblinka.
And um,
my mother would say it was a company,
nation of premonition dreams.
She was very,
very superstitious and she really believed her dreams that would tell her
tomorrow,
don't go there tomorrow,
be a little bit late there tomorrow.
Make sure to have an extra layer of newspaper on your feet because it's going to
be really,
really cold.
She had all these premonitions dreams of her father talking to her and things
like that.
And she will always say chance came first.
My father too.
I think ultimately both of them said chance came first and then there was what
you did with the chance that was given to you.
Right.
Um,
and so there was always a mixture between choice and coincidence,
choice and chance.
And um,
my mother said she always made sure that she was clean,
that she was groomed,
that she was mending her socks,
that she maintained her humanity,
that she didn't allow herself to become the humanized and degraded the way that
she was being treated by the night.
And my father,
um,
my father,
when we were,
we went to visit Auschwitz actually ended up telling me a story of,
of a Dutch convoy that arrived of women.
And he somehow picked a woman out of the crowd and he decided that he would help
this woman and basically the next day they were shaven.
And so he couldn't even recognize her.
So he asked the capable,
who is the other woman that he had mentioned notice the day before?
And they began some correspondence,
which I have no idea how he wrote because he couldn't write.
And I never bothered asking him who wrote for you?
But he fell in love with this woman and he just decided that they were certain
things that,
that the Germans can take away from him.
Um,
and that had to do with feelings and we'd love in the most dire of
circumstances.
Um,
and then he basically developed this black market in one of the camps where he
was with his best friend,
where they were for almost a year and a half,
where he ended up feeding 60 young men who would otherwise not have had enough
to eat and therefore to work and therefore to survive.
And he ended up feeding the Nazis too.
So when he got caught with those letters,
one of the Germans basically sent him back to the factories and said,
you're not staying in here.
You can factories manager,
do you have one week to live?
Basically.
And uh,
but he had been feeding the German guy so well that the guy said,
I eat better when you work in the kitchens and he put him back in the kitchen.
And so you always said it was a combination of chance and ingenuity streetsmart
what he would call.
Um,
and,
and doing for others,
doing for others give you a purpose to stay alive and to wake up in the morning.
If you look at then the survivors,
whether by chance first like you mentioned choice,
some combination of those factors and others you mentioned survival and revival.
When you look at the survivors who ended up being able to revive themselves and
to,
and who did not.
So the third reason my mother always said is that she always thought that they
wanted her to stay alive because if the others were not going to be make it,
they needed to be at least someone from the family.
And she always thought that she would somehow be reunited with somebody.
So she maintained this very deep connection inside of her,
um,
that they were waiting for her somewhere.
Um,
then they realize that there was nobody.
So I,
you know,
it's an interesting question that I organized in my mind like this.
And I organized it when I was actually writing,
meeting,
uh,
my first book,
mating in captivity.
I the time I had a conversation with my husband and I who was working with
survivors of torture and political violence,
and I would ask him,
when do you know that people come back and what does it mean to come back?
Right?
Come back from,
from different war zones to come back from having been kidnapped,
to come back from solitary confinement and w and what does it mean to come back
to life.
And then as we were talking,
you know,
it became very clear that when you reconnect with life,
not just when you are surviving,
but when you are living,
it means that you once again able to take risks,
able to broach out,
go into the world,
able to play because you cannot play if you are in a constant state of vigilance
and guardedness and able to trust.
And then I thought to myself,
oh my God,
this is so much what I saw in Antwerp.
You know,
I remember since my entire classroom where children of similar families that
they were always two groups of families in my community.
And then I decided that I would call this,
there was one group that did not die and one group that came back to life and
the did not die.
You could feel it when you went to their houses.
You know,
they often had plastics over the,
the couches and the,
the curtains were pulled down.
It was more bit,
it was just,
you know,
you,
you're not dead but you not celebrating yet.
Life you certainly are not enjoying because if you enjoy,
then you are not being careful and you have guilt.
You often have survivor guilt.
Why am I here?
And none of the others made it.
Um,
and you are way too down in the world is a dangerous place and you are not to
trust anyone outside the family.
And all of that.
And then I taught there is those who came back to life.
And that's,
that's what led me actually to really want to explore what is erotic racism?
What is this antidote to that?
How in the face of adversity do you continue to imagine yourself and you know,
rising above it,
connected to joy,
to love,
to pleasure,
uh,
to beauty,
to adventure,
to mystery,
to all of that.
And um,
and that,
those people,
you know,
it was very interesting,
you had people who came together because they were the survivors of this camp
and the survivors of that cap.
And then you had people who came together for this kind of holiday or that kind
of celebration.
And they never discussed their experiences.
It was all implicit,
but they were together.
Andy,
they were charging ahead at life.
You know,
the first thing they did when they would come out of the camps,
by the way,
is have a child because I'm alone.
You're alone.
I have nothing.
You have nothing.
Let's get married and let's have children.
Because if we have a child and we know that we are still human,
we are able to procreate and we create legacy and they didn't kill everything
off.
And so my parents,
you know,
they planted trees in all kinds of places in the world.
They put plaques on in the memory of all the other people have their families.